the obama era daca program will reach
its 10th anniversary this year as part
of that milestone dozens of scholarships
are up for grabs to help the so-called
dreamers further their education
christian casares joining us live in our
studio with more on who christian is
behind the effort well brian daca which
is short for the deferred action for
childhood arrivals program has helped
thousands thousands of undocumented
immigrants over the past 10 years and
now the mexican consulate in las vegas
wants to help for one local dreamer that
helping hand could mean a college degree
every little bit of money is incredibly
helpful you know like either it pays for
my school or pays for my transportation
22 year old daniel lara works hard every
day to achieve his dream of becoming a
college graduate a dream that he says is
difficult to obtain because of his legal
status i needed a job that was legal and
i needed to be able to apply to you know
higher education and i couldn't be able
to do that without any sort of
you know legality in the country laura
is one of the estimated 11 000
beneficiaries in nevada enrolled in the
daca program according to the mexican
consulate in las vegas the obama air
initiative provides legal status and
work permits for undocumented immigrants
brought to the country as children as it
reaches its first decade more help is on
the way many undocumented youth do not
have access to financial financial
assistance so we do have
a scholarship program that is open now
for applications up to 2500 will be
awarded to an estimated 50 daca winners
to further their education thanks to
private donations funds that the council
of mexico and las vegas says can go a
long way for those with limited to no
resources they do not have access to
financial assistance there's no federal
or state
programs for them since 2017 laura has
taken full advantage of the benefits of
the daca program although daca has no
path to citizenship he says his
education is priceless if one day they
decide to take it out then it's like i
can't work go to work no more i can't go
to school no more
all right applications for the
scholarship are now open and the winners
will be announced on august 10th now if
you're interested we have a link to
apply on our website eight newsnow dot
com christian cousin is live local now